y
[Música]
donald trump y joe biden siguen a la
conquista de votantes indecisos en
estados claves en el último fin de
semana antes de las elecciones
el demócrata apareció acompañado por el
ex presidente barack obama mientras que
trump dedicó su energía en pensilvania
más de 90 millones de personas ya han
votado anticipadamente
europa es golpeada de lleno por la
segunda ola de kobe 19 reino unido
vuelve a combinarse durante 4 semanas
tras superar el millón de contagios en
austria las restricciones serán más
moderadas pero también con cierres de
hoteles y restaurantes y portugal ordenó
el confinamiento de 70 por ciento de su
población
los argelinos votan sobre una
constitución renovada destinada a
otorgar más poder al parlamento las
urnas abrieron este domingo para elegir
o rechazar esta actualización de la
carta magna- donde el gobierno espera
que sea una nueva era en el país y darle
a la ciudadanía nuevas libertades pero
los críticos aseguran que los cambios
son superficiales
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 se hablan con
gusto saludarlos comenzamos este
informativo con los últimos esfuerzos
con miras a seducir a los votantes de
los estados clave de cara a las
elecciones estadounidenses del próximo 3
de noviembre el demócrata joe biden se
concentró en michigan acompañado por el
ex presidente barack obama mientras que
el republicano donald trump realizó
varios actos políticos en pensilvania
donde según sus predicciones
habrá una ola roja de votos republicanos
más de 90 millones de personas ya
votaron anticipadamente lo equivalente
al 65 por ciento de la votación total
del año 2016 este fin de semana es el
final antes de las elecciones en ese
país veamos cómo estuvo la jornada
frente a la llegada al día de los
comicios en estados claves como michigan
pensilvania
sacando la artillería pesada
barack obama apareció nuevamente en
campaña para apoyar a su
exvicepresidente al pronunciarse este
michigan un estado tradicionalmente de
izquierda pero en el que hillary clinton
perdió en 2016
entiendo que este es un presidente que
quiere ganarse el crédito completo por
la economía que heredó y no tener
ninguna culpa por la pandemia que ignoro
pero el trabajo no funciona de esa
manera
twittear no soluciona las cosas inventar
cosas no mejora la vida de las personas
debes tener un plan tienes que hacer el
trabajo
mientras tanto donald trump estuvo
concentrado en pensilvania donde realizó
cuatro actos de campaña este sábado
en esta área una de las principales en
materia de producción de gas natural
trump insistió en que su rival abolir a
la industria petrolera de eeuu y
prohibir a el fracking
hace unos momentos firmé una orden para
proteger el fracking en pensilvania y
bloquear cualquier esfuerzo para reducir
la producción de energía en este estado
lo firme en el hermoso mar in one vieron
eso
trump sigue realizando grandes
encuentros con sus partidarios ignorando
las medidas de distanciamiento social el
mandatario estadounidense ha preferido
evitar enfocarse en el manejo de la
pandemia el país registró más de 100.000
nuevos casos el viernes un récord
mundial las encuestas recientes indican
que su rival joe biden le lleva una
ventaja pero trump prevé otra sorpresiva
victoria
seguimos en américa del norte porque en
canadá a la policía de quebec arrestó a
un hombre por un ataque con arma blanca
que dejó dos personas muertas y otras
cinco heridas la noche de halloween los
hechos se produjeron en cercanías del
parlamento local y según los informes de
la policía el sospechoso que fue llevada
a un hospital junto a los heridos iba
disfrazado con un atuendo medieval en el
momento del ataque hasta ahora no se
conocen detalles sobre los posibles
motivos
el incidente violento registrado en
quebec coincide con varios ataques
registrados en las últimas semanas en
francia tras la publicación de
caricaturas del profeta mahoma que han
despertado la ira del mundo musulmán
el presidente de manuel macrón habló por
primera vez desde el inicio de las
revueltas en contra de francia en
distintos países en una entrevista con
la cadena al yazira dijo que entiende la
rabia musulmana pero también que no hay
justificación para actos violentos
veamos
casi dos semanas después de que las
palabras del presidente emmanuel macon
en defensa de la libertad y la
posibilidad de hacer caricaturas del
profeta mahoma causarán furia en el
mundo musulmán el presidente de
indonesia el país con la mayor población
musulmana del mundo envía un mensaje de
calma aunque condenó los comentarios del
mandatario francés en un ayamonte
sampras
indonesia condena la violencia en parís
y niza que ha cobrado vidas sin embargo
indonesia también condena fuertemente
las declaraciones del presidente francés
porque ha insultado al islam hiriendo
los sentimientos de los musulmanes
alrededor del mundo y podría dividir la
unidad de los creyentes e zombis logró
tenía el 21 de octubre durante el
homenaje nacional a samuel para ti el
profesor que fue asesinado por mostrar
imágenes del profeta mahoma en su clase
el presidente francés hizo declaraciones
con respecto al derecho a las
caricaturas
desde entonces ha habido docenas de
manifestaciones en contra de francia
llamados a no comprar productos de la
nación europea
mccomb extendió su mensaje yo como
respect confitado entiendo y respeto la
ira de las personas con respecto a las
caricaturas nunca aceptaré la
justificación de la violencia física por
estas caricaturas de fondo movie y
siempre defenderé la libertad de hablar
escribir pensar y dibujar en mi país
desde cine otras figuras del gobierno
francés han intentado también ponerle
fin a la controversia
sin embargo macon sigue siendo impopular
gran parte del mundo musulmán
cambiamos ahora información europa vivió
una jornada en la que países como reino
unido austria grecia o portugal
decidieron implementar confinamientos
totales o parciales para frenar la
segunda ola de coronavirus en la región
las restricciones suponen un nuevo golpe
para la economía alentando protestas en
diversos sectores veamos el siguiente
informe
inglaterra se configura durante un mes
bares restaurantes y actividades no
esenciales cerrarán desde el próximo
jueves hasta el 2 de diciembre escocia
gales e irlanda del norte tendrán
autonomía sobre los tierras
ahora es momento de tomar medidas porque
no hay alternativa desde el jueves hasta
principios de diciembre debemos
quedarnos en casa
y sólo se podrá salir por cuestiones
específicas incluyendo educación trabajo
si es que no se puede hacer desde casa
para hacer ejercicio y recreación al
aire libre
por razones médicas y para escapar de
lesiones o daños
intuit
para comprar alimentos y artículos
básicos y para brindar atención a
personas vulnerables como voluntarios de
provincia algo que se replica en casi
toda europa austria también impuso un
confinamiento de un mes y cierre de
establecimientos no esenciales algo que
ya provocó protestas frente a la sede
gubernamental
grecia tendrá un cierre parcial donde
solo se verán afectados hoteles
restaurantes y la industria de la
cultura pero el comercio seguirá
operando en portugal por su parte se
anunció que el 70% de la población
estará confinada desde el 4 de noviembre
y en italia ante la posibilidad de
restricciones más duras cientos de
personas salieron a la calle a pedir
ayuda económica ver qué habitante que
está claro que la crisis que seguirá y
que ha dañado la economía la pagará la
población y estamos aquí para hacer que
los patrones paguen la crisis en la
moscú belfast para caer a la crisis de
patrón ya el primer confinamiento ya
golpeó con dureza a la mayoría de países
europeos que vieron caídas históricas en
su pib ahora miles de personas temen que
otro encierro sea el golpe definitivo a
sus negocios y puestos de trabajo
vamos ahora con noticias de medio
oriente cientos de israelíes protestaron
en contra del primer ministro benjamin
netanyahu por su presunta corrupción y
el manejo del gobierno de la pandemia de
kobe 19 la multitud se reunió frente a
la residencia de netanyahu soplando
silbatos agitando carteles y banderas
además pidiendo su renuncia la policía
israelí declaró que se detuvo a seis
manifestantes que provocaron disturbios
el país actualmente se encuentra en
recesión como resultado de la pandemia y
la tasa de desempleo se sitúa por encima
del 11%
en áfrica 25 millones de votantes están
llamados a las urnas hoy en argelia para
pronunciarse sobre los cambios
propuestos a la constitución el
presidente abdel majid won cree que una
carta magna- actualizada será el punto
de partida para una nueva era en el país
y subraya que los cambios responden a
muchas de las demandas del girar el
movimiento de protesta contra el
gobierno el mandatario asegura querer
imponer límites para el número de
mandatos y darle a la ciudadanía nuevas
libertades pero los críticos aseguran
que los cambios son puramente
superficiales
lo que comenzó como un amistoso juego de
azar rápidamente se convirtió en un
estratégico referendo constitucional y
muchos argelinos creen que la votación
no llevará a muchos cambios
como de costumbre votarán en mi nombre
lo han hecho desde 1962 así que déjennos
continuar
he leído la constitución y no me
conviene
cuando nos llaman para votar respondemos
pero después cuando hay problemas los
políticos no se encuentran en ninguna
parte nuestros hijos no tienen trabajos
no hay vivienda no hay nada
el presidente abdel me diste boom afirma
que las reformas constitucionales
propuestas cumplen con las exigencias de
las protestas antigubernamentales del
irak un movimiento que ha visto a miles
de personas salir a las calles pidiendo
el fin de la corrupción las protestas
semanales lograron forzar la salida del
ex presidente abdelaziz buteflika en
2019 después de que se mantuviera en el
poder durante 20 años y para muchos es
el irak lo que está en la papeleta
electoral en este referéndum
todo el mundo debería ir a las urnas
porque hay injusticia en este país esta
constitución es el remedio para todo y
sería bueno que el pueblo votará sí a la
constitución
cuando el presidente de wulff fue
elegido el año pasado solicitó dialogar
con el irak algunos dicen que la
constitución reformada muestra que
cumplió su promesa el texto propone en
efecto nuevas libertades para permitir a
los militares argelinos intervenir en el
exterior e impone límites a la duración
de los mandatos
la constitución sigue dando al
presidente la mayoría de los poderes por
eso para los activistas prodemocracia
que quieren una renovación completa de
la clase política de argelia estos
cambios no bastan
y actualizamos ahora la información
sobre turquía donde aumentó a 51 el
número de víctimas mortales por el
terremoto que sacudió el mar egeo el
pasado viernes dos de los muertos se
registraron en la isla griega de samos
en la ciudad turca de esmirna la más
afectada por el sismo más de 100
personas ya han sido sacadas entre los
escombros la última persona rescatada
con vida hasta el momento fue un hombre
de 70 años de edad que permaneció
durante 33 horas atrapado bajo los
escombros
el partido laborista de la primera
ministra de nueva zelanda ya sin a harén
firmó un acuerdo con el partido verde
para formar gobierno en la nación del
pacífico de casi 5 millones de
habitantes ahora en a principios de este
mes logró la mayor victoria la mayor
victoria electoral de su partido en
medio siglo aunque ya no necesita el
apoyo de otros partidos para poder
gobernar las coaliciones son la norma en
nueva zelanda ya que los partidos buscan
construir un consenso los verdes están
obligados a respaldar al gobierno pero
por los más partidos tienen derecho a
adoptar una posición diferente a los de
los laboristas
en méxico andrés manuel lópez obrador me
inauguró varias ofrendas a los
fallecidos por el coi 19 con motivo de
la conmemoración del día de los muertos
la tradicional festividad se celebrará
con muchas restricciones a causa de esta
pandemia de ccoo y 19 que todos vivimos
y que azota al país este cap el
mandatario anunció que como tributo a
las víctimas méxico guardará tres días
de luto veamos el informe que ha
preparado álvaro cordero
[Música]
méxico rinde homenaje a los fallecidos
por el cómic 19 con motivo de la
celebración del día de muertos
andrés manuel lópez obrador inauguró
varios altares con ofrendas clásicas de
este día y anunció que el país entraría
en tres días de luto oficial por las
víctimas a partir de hoy
se inician tres días de luto nacional
dedicados a recordar
a todos nuestros difuntos
y en especial
a quienes han perdido la vida
a causa de la pandemia
del cobi 19 esta tradicional festividad
mexicana está marcada este año por la
pandemia algunos estados han prohibido o
restringido la entrada a cementerios por
lo que en el palacio nacional se
levantaron 20 ofrendas y se honró a los
pueblos originarios que también
estuvieron presentes pues es lamentable
y triste guardar de que estemos viviendo
en esta época de gran epidemia pero
bueno
el hombre tiene que estar siempre
preparado antes
situaciones siempre tiene que aprender
de esto la pandemia ha golpeado con
dureza a méxico es el décimo país con
más contagios contabilizados del mundo y
el cuarto con más muertes y la causa de
muerte por kobe 19 ya es la tercera más
habitual en el país tan sólo superada
por la diabetes y las enfermedades del
corazón
y esta manera llegamos al final del
informativo en france 24 contenido con
nosotros para más actualización de
noticias feliz domingo
[Música]
todas las ruedas